un pas presque militaires réglés au
millimètre accompagné d'un chant de
rassemblant une tradition immuable qui
remonte à la création de l'école des
arts et métiers
[Musique]
mais depuis quelques années les période
d'intégration ont été comparés à des
bizutages qui part soit trouvée dégénéré
et un travail presque six mois sur
redonner des objectifs de valeur et
voilà de repenser l'ensemble de ce qui
se passait en accueille des étudiants en
première année donc avec les premières
années on a des réunions pratiquement
toutes les semaines avec les deuxièmes
années en responsabilité aussi pour
pouvoir préparer chaque événement le
cadre est
c'est un travail que l'on a avec la
direction avec les anciens élèves pour
organiser au mieux cette période
justement pour éviter toute dérive il
aura fallu deux mois de préparation pour
que ce défilé un mono en langage
étudiants soit parfait et pour les
nouveaux arrivants cette période
d'intégration s'est bien déroulé je ne
connaissais pas grand chose mais dès
qu'on a déjà commencé à parler des arts
et métiers autour de moi on m'a mis en
garde contre le bizutage est en fait il
n'y en a pas il y en a plus aujourd'hui
ils ont réussi à faire une période
d'intégration sans alcool et sans
contact
même si ça prend du temps j'ai trouvé ça
assez génial parce que ça change
vraiment du travail
le monôme c'est qu'en plus dans les rues
de cluny avec des anciens élèves tous
les étudiants de l'école vont désormais
s'atteler ensemble à la préparation des
autres manifestations
barça